I like powders legal powders I might add
nothing else hi GQ this is Simon Pegg
and these are the items I cannot live
without
this is hot sauce Cholula it's a classic
it's a lovely entry-level hot sauce this
one if you're just starting out and
you're trying to sort of ease your way
into burning face I kind of just love
the pain although this isn't
particularly painful this one there are
ones out there that will actually cause
you physical damage I do have this one
which is um like an oil and you put it
on a cocktail stick and you just put it
on your tongue like that and you have
eight minutes of flaming Agony but it
gets you quite high and as someone who
is completely sober and doesn't partake
of any other stimulants other than
caffeine it's a nice little bonus
[Music]
Chanel anteus I like to have a specific
smell I don't like to chop and change my
scents some guys have like a day scent
and an evening scent but I just really
love this I feel like it's a bit me I've
had people say that they were on the bus
or something and and someone was wearing
this and they thought oh Simon's on the
bus but I think they might be
discontinuing it which is which is a
tragedy I'll have to get a new smell and
then no one will know who I am I'm
terrified young Greg Tarzan Davis who is
a new addition to the Mission Impossible
cast plays Agent dagar who at the
premiere of Mission Impossible in New
York we had a what I can only describe
as a scent Collision he was wearing a
beautiful Armani suit I saw him I needed
to touch him we embraced and our scents
combined in the air into some super
scent that a lot of people around men
and women became spontaneously aroused
this is a really obvious one it would be
a lie to say that this isn't probably
the most essential item to me it's an
office it's a recreational tool it's
it's a viewer of media and I generally
always have it in my hand much to my
wife's sugaring you know it's got all my
photographs it's got my entire
daughter's life on it so I have uh
thousands and thousands of photos
documenting her entire life which is
incredibly important to me you
invariably start a group chat with your
fellow cast members crew members
whatever so yes I have a Star Trek group
group chat and a mission group chat Tom
Cruise is is probably the most famous
person in my phone he's not in there
under his name he's under a fake name
it's always a bit of a thrill to get a
text from Tom unsolicited it makes me
laugh when when something comes in and
because my wife uh teases me that I love
him
I do so when I get a text I'm like oh
look look who's takes away oh it's your
boyfriend she says
this which I'm wearing right now is a
Tiffany dog tag that my wife gave me and
it's inscribed with SM and M which is
Simon Maureen and Matilda this is
something I wear when I'm away just
because it you know it it keeps them
close it's difficult one of the hardest
things about my job is is having to to
leave home all the time I don't really
like leaving so this helps me just to
sort of like keep them close to my heart
sickening absolutely sickening here are
my powders I like powders legal powders
I might add nothing else these are
athletic greens or ag1 it basically
gives you all the greens that you need
for the day whatever it is at the moment
you're 12 a day whatever because it is
actual veg Crush into a powder but it
has like 75 vitamins in it I'm reading
the back now
ag1 Sammy
this
is protein powder from form it's always
good to go for a clean protein this is a
vegan protein powder I'm not a vegan but
I I appreciate veganosity even if I
don't understand it and this is
something I will have after my workout a
mission impossible is responsible for
getting me into Fitness in my later life
when you look at me and Mission
Impossible three I literally look like a
potato in a cardigan so when it came to
do Ghost Protocol I'd kind of just
discovered the gym I'm not planning on
doing any Tom Cruise level stunts but
planning is not a thing that you ever
can really do when you make a mission
impossible movie you have to just allow
it I don't think I could ever get the
script and read it and it says Benji
paraglides into a shark's anus and and
I'd have to say fine I'll do that I'll
fly right into that thing it means
something to the audience if they can
see that it's the actor doing this done
so if he asked me
to jump off a cliff on a motorcycle
I would which reminds me of that old
thing my mom used to say oh well if your
friends ask you to jump off a cliff
would you I guess the answer finally is
yes
[Music]
coffee I love love love coffee and it's
something that I I look forward to in
the evening before I go to bed that I'm
gonna have one in the morning it's my
last remaining Vice really caffeine if
you can call it advice and that first
little hit in the morning is uh is an
absolute Delight growing up as a Brit I
I was tea I was a tea man you know I
started drinking coffee the first time I
came to New York with Edgar Wright we
used to come at the end of the century
a long time ago we used to come to New
York to buy DVDs we'd go and you know do
loads of New Yorker stuff and we go to
Kim's video in some Mark's Place and buy
American DVDs because American DVDs had
loads of extras on back in the day so
we'd come over to New York we'd stay at
the Soho Grand and then in the morning
we'd come down and there was free coffee
free coffee and it just became a
religion to me after that
okay this is a basic style staple I
think it's the Henley t-shirt which is a
design classic it's comfortable it's
stylish it's slightly rugged shows off
my guns a little bit
the Henley generally speaking though
because I'm such a homebody I spend my
life in sweatpants in a henley t-shirt
that's where I'm most comfortable to do
this kind of thing and to get out there
and and get to dress up is a real thrill
because I so rarely do it I don't go out
I don't go to parties I'm married I have
a child you know the primary reasons for
going out is to get pissed and get laid
I don't need to do either of those
things
I freaking love sunglasses that and the
right headphones for my snowboarding
helmet are the things that I spent the
most money on these are some of the
sunglasses that I bought out on this
press store so get together with my
stylist Arabella and we get an outfit
when we get a look we'll pair it with
exactly the right pair of sunglasses for
instance these would look nice with this
suit because they have blue lenses and
so you're pairing the blue with the uh
with the blue and suit and the blue of
the background which I asked to be
arranged for me so I wouldn't coordinate
this entire studio today I probably have
a few hundred pairs at home I lose them
a lot that annoys me I lost a lovely
pair of aviators in Rome I'm still
gutted about that
music is such a huge part of my life my
father is a musician and um I grew up
you know listening to me I listen to
music constantly I'm a bit of an old
Indie kid I have a very broad music
taste much broader than than when I was
younger and I was very tribal with my
music it was like my music's cool and
everyone else's music is shite but now
I'm much more sort of egalitarian when
it comes to my music taste I I my
daughter I went through a sort of uh
K-pop phase she was big into BTS when
she first talked about it I was like
what that's like a boy band why are you
into a boy band and she said no listen
to this and she played me a couple of
songs and I was like yeah yeah this is
pretty good certainly those BTS boys are
an incredible tight outfit they're all
beautiful they've done some amazing
Tunes the Steve Aoki remix of mic drop
is is one of my favorite songs it's just
such a banger so yeah that's that for
for a 53 year old you know Indie kid
um that might surprise people
foreign
items that I like to use this is a my
zone essentially it's a heart rate
monitor you pair it with your phone on
the app and it tells you when you're in
certain zones of heart rate so you're in
gray blue green yellow or red and you
can tailor your workouts to sort of stay
in certain zones or kind of only reach a
certain Zone and you can see how quickly
you recover back into the gray zone or
whatever this is a lumen and this is a
metabolism tracker you wake up in the
morning and you blow into it and it
tells you what your body is doing in
terms of what it's burning so if you're
burning carbs mainly and if you're
burning fats it'll tell you yeah I mean
aside from the kind of you know the
Euphoria of physical fitness we try and
keep things as light as possible on set
and Tom is a bit of a prankster and he's
kind of not feeling the weight of the of
the movie on him he can be extremely
mischievous and we've had several
occasions when he would switch on my
seat heater uh when we're in Morocco
when we were doing the car chase in
Morocco so that I kept overheating and I
didn't know why and it was because he
kept switching my see heater on he'll
always sort of just move into shot when
when we're doing Mike say with shooting
me now and we're doing my dialogue and
it's what's called a dirty so you can
see Tom's shoulder he'll just creep so
he blocks me it's like an ongoing War we
have to upstage each other it's fun
making films and it should be fun
because we're essentially playing and
that's what filmmaking is thanks GQ this
has been a blast I've really enjoyed uh
demonstrating My Essentials to you I'll
see you soon thanks for watching go see
Mission Impossible dead reckoning part
one on the biggest screen you possibly
can